IT IS TIME FOR TONIGHT'S HASHTAG WAR!
( CHEERS AND APPLAUSE )
TODAY IS VETERANS DAY.
IF YOU ARE A VETERAN, THANK YOU FOR
SERVICE TO OUR COUNTRY.
BUT THAT ALSO--
( APPLAUSE ).
>> YES, YES.
THAT ALSO MEANS BESIDES THANKING
AND HONORING VETERANS WE WATCHED
ACTION MOVIE MARATHONS ON TV ALL
DAY.
WITH THAT IN MIND, TONIGHT'S
HASHTAG IS #SUCKYACTIONMOVIES.
EXAMPLES OF THESE MIGHT BE DIE
SOFT.
OR HOBO COP.
OR TOYOTATHON MAN.
YOU GUYS CAN PLAY ALONG AT HOME
BY TWEETING YOUR
#SUCKYACTIONMOVIES TO THE
"@MIDNIGHT" TWITTER ACCOUNT.
KURT.
>> IRONING MAN.
>> POINT, POINTS.
>> THE FLIRT LOCKER!
( LAUGHTER ).
>> POINTS!
YES, COUNTER.
>> THE SQUIRT LOCKER.
>> THAT'SSUCKY AND DISTURBING.
POINTS.
YES, HODGMAN.
>> LEE CHILD'S CRANK TWO HIGH
VOLTAGE.
>> POINT, POINTS KURT.
>> THE PERMNATOR.
>> GRACE.
E ROBOT.>> OH, GOOD-BYE ROBOT.BY
>> IT'S A BISEXUAL ROBOT.
>> I CANNOT DECIDE I LIKE AC AND
DC.
( LAUGHTER )
( APPLAUSE ).
>> PLANET OF THE GRAPES.
>> PLANET OF THE GRAPES WOULD BE
A REALLY SUCKY ACTION MOVIE.
♪ IT WAS EARTH ALL ALONG ♪ ♪.
>> ALIEN DEFENDS PREDATOR.
>> VERY SWEET.
MAYBE NOT SO SUCKY.
GRACE, LAST ONE.
>> JAW!
( LAUGHTER )
( APPLAUSE )
WELL DONE!
MERRY CHRISTMAS OLIVER.
>> THE CHILD HAS DONE WELL!
THE CHILD HAS DONE WELL!
>> WHO'S GOT HALF A BRAIN NOW